so let's talk about Kanye because I know
you got some thoughts on Kanye I'm going
to read both stories Adam and you can
comment on it I'll go first with uh his
comments about George Floyd and we'll go
into what 50 Cent said uh uh so I think
that's on page
uh six or seven is it six okay six uh
here we go so Connie West apologizes for
spreading Lies by George Floyd's that
this is uh Kanye offered what the media
is calling an apology for comments he
made in reference to George Floyd if we
call Wester recently declared that Floyd
died from Fentanyl and now due to
homicide under the knee of the Derek
chovin when I see that video as a black
person it hurts my feelings and I know
that police do attack and what America
is generally and that America is
generally racist and I understand that
when we got to say black lives matter
the idea of it made us feel good
together as people now afterwards there
were uh there were some things where the
money went in order to push us to uh the
Democratic vote so when I questioned The
Death of George Floyd it hurt my people
I want to apologize because God has
showed me by what Adidas is doing by
what the media is doing I know what it
feels to have a knee on my neck right
now so and then 50 Cent came out and
said Kanye should Master the art of
shutting the up okay that's what he said
I've seen people in this position
because of uh things they have done not
things they have said now you gotta
Master the art of shutting the hell up
the rapper was reportedly reacting to
CNN Headline alleging West has a
disturbing history of admiring
Hitler I have never seen anything like
this before a screenshot I think Kanye
should buy the car he likes the best and
just ride off into the sunset it's
really a wrap people are really hurt by
this [ __ ] us and there's a bunch of
other things that came after that black
people are actually uh anyways these are
the comments he made about Jews and
blacks and comparing them so Adam
thoughts on the story look I haven't
really been
obviously I've been following Kanye well
for you obviously decades now but
obviously over the last few weeks I
haven't really been
too opinionated because I was more
asking questions than making statements
something that I think we could all kind
of get behind like before you start oh I
believe this I say this like let's hear
let's hear him out and see what he has
to say with that being said I've really
had an opportunity to kind of process
what's going on with Kanye and then to a
bigger context like the groups or the
people that he's really hurting so
number one
um
Kanye is a musical genius I'm I like I'm
okay with saying that like he's created
Amazing Music he's he's he's a
Trailblazer he's awesome in that regard
but the problem with Geniuses sometimes
is they even as great as they are in
their respective careers they have blind
spots okay so Kanye what are some of his
blind spots clearly he's a narcissist
clearly he has a God complex he doesn't
know how to just be a normal guy why
would he he's been pedestaled and
elevated and coddled everywhere he's
gone over the last 10 20 years because
of the greatness that he's reached so if
you have these blind spots you don't
know how to treat people you don't know
how to interact with people you're not a
man of the people you're doing things
for the attention of your brand Okay so
you can be a genius but also have major
issues in your situation but a lot of
what
people aren't really addressing about
Kanye and I've said this before and I'll
say it again is the influence that the
Kardashian female matriarchy has had on
this man's life I've said this before
again we all know my history with the
Kardashians my best friend Kris
Humphries married Kim 2011. I live the
Kardashian life for a [ __ ] year I saw
this lifestyle I saw this bubble and I
saw the head of the matriarchy Kris
Jenner and her influence over all the
women in this family but let's look at
what's happened to all the men in this
family and that's what people are not
addressing with Kanye like all right
we'll start with Bruce Jenner this was a
like world famous Olympian decathlon uh
goat and now he's a transgender woman
okay cool the father dead how did he die
like at a young age I don't know I'm not
that's not a conspiracy I'm just saying
he's died at a young age if you go down
the list Lamar Odom turned in from an
NBA athlete to a literal crackhead okay
Scott Disick who is a good looking young
guy would ever rehab Galore and I'm
friends with him so I'm not talking [ __ ]
if you when you look at
um the other men in the family Rob
Kardashian is a recluse hasn't been seen
in years the women run the show in that
family so when you bring in a leader
like Kanye a man like a man who like has
conviction and you kind of feminize him
and say we run the show now and he
already has mental health issues and
bipolar Tendencies like how do you
expect him to react and then final point
to the Kim K thing is
dude he's been completely
demasculated with this whole Pete
Davidson situation where you're going to
leave your husband Kim K and start
parading with this [ __ ] joke of a guy
Pete Davidson what do you think that's
going to do to someone who has a fragile
ego and a fragile mental capacity
already despite his you know amazing
gifts like that's gonna [ __ ] you up so
what he's doing and what he's feeling
there's so much going on that it's hard
to kind of put your self in Kanye's
shoes because you don't know like when
you're operating at such a high level
even Rogan said like when you plug in
you see what he said about like a
hundred electricity vaults and and
that's something that's only has a 40
watt capacity there's so much going on
that how can you restrain that with that
being said that doesn't excuse what he's
been saying specifically about Jews now
any time that you paint a group whether
it's blacks gays Jews Asians this and
you start group talking rather than
individuals that's going to be a problem
and as a Jew initially I didn't
overreact we've had multiple shows about
Kanye I haven't gone off like the wire
but here's what I've learned about Jews
especially talking with friends and
especially being around Miami Beach and
seeing what's going on Jews are not
[ __ ] playing anymore
all right we're not [ __ ] playing
everything that's happened in Jewish
history
culminating with the Holocaust which
eventually led to the creation of the
state of Israel in 1948 there's been a
run-up of Jews being the scapegoat and
being the bad guy and being the person
or the group of people that were the the
reasons why societies have not thrived
and were declining and it ended with the
final solution that Hitler tried to
accomplish murdering six million Jews
and at some point Jews were like that's
it and there's a saying in Judaism never
again
so when there's even like a a small blip
on the radar of people painting Jews to
be whatever as he grounds well within
Jews we're like that ain't [ __ ]
happening and like if you look at the
creation of Israel and what they've been
able to do over the last 50 60 years and
become the great powerful Nation where
you're you're the size of [ __ ]
Delaware amongst a sea of Arab people
that have always wanted your death and
you see what Israel has turned into in
the IDF and Mossad and what that's
turned into it's Jews are just not going
to accept this anymore so by default
there's going to be a defensive reaction
and also an offensive reaction by Jews
to say listen Kanye shut the [ __ ] up
we're not playing like that we're not
playing this game you've tried to murder
every single one of our people we're not
even allowing this to happen and then
for I'll give you one final case example
for like the people out there that are
like well the Jews they're all in
cahoots and they run the world it's like
well let's like look here politically in
America two of the biggest fundraisers
for in politics on the those are Jews on
the left you can point to George Soros
he has a very specific agenda whether
you agree with it or disagree with it we
know that he has an agenda and on the
right side of things
uh rest in peace with Sheldon Adelson
hardcore Republican hardcore
conservative Heart Like
multi-multi-multi millions and billions
of dollars that they've both put into
the system now if Jews are in cahoots to
run the world why would two famous
Jewish billionaires be completely
funding complete opposite agendas like
give me an answer to that so anyway
that's my thoughts on Kanye and anytime
you label a group you're going to have
an issue especially these days as the
Jews I love two of the things you talk
first of all the anti-semitic stuff he
says is just bad I mean people should
just be able to look at that and just
say all right this is just bad and I
think you have seen a lot of people
rally you know with the Jewish Community
who are tired of the way anti-Semitism
has been tolerated by many for a very
long time are saying enough Kanye listen
I oftentimes listen to him and I have to
be honest I don't understand a lick of
what he's saying I don't understand a
lot of what he's saying I I almost feel
like this guy is trying to figure out
how he feels about stuff out loud and he
should just take a minute to just maybe
he's not used to being in the Limelight
maybe he's not you in terms of talking
about his opinions you know he's getting
invited on Fox news shows this is new
for him this is different it's different
it's one thing to be an artist and to
have an opinion it's another thing you
know to be front and center in these
types of interviews I think he needs to
sit back and he needs to think a little
bit about how he feels about stuff about
what he might be asked about what he's
comfortable putting out there it seems
to me now that this stuff about George
Floyd he's walking this back saying you
know well I needed to clarify I need
well that involves thinking about how
you really feel about issues and
understanding that once you put it out
there it's very hard to say oh no
actually what I really meant is this so
even though he's famous he's front and
center for his you know artistic work
and all of that he hasn't been famous in
this way you know you know looking to
become the CEO of parlor and getting
highly political when it comes to his
content and when you get highly
political every time you know I always
say every time I open my mouth half the
country's Gonna Hate what I say but a
lot of it is very well thought out
beforehand you know I want to make sure
I'm comfortable with what I'm saying if
I'm comfortable with what I'm saying
cool half the country can hate what I'm
saying but I don't know that he's always
comfortable with the message he's
putting out there then there seems to be
a some reflection and then he kind of
changes it so he just needs to
understand he's in new Turf right now
and he's going to be held accountable
for the things he says when it comes to
politics when it comes to comments like
this so This anti-semitic stuff rubs a
lot of people wrong rightfully so I love
that angle you took with the Kardashians
the Kardashian culture is incredibly
toxic I mean that is you want to talk
about we we talk about toxic masculinity
that's actually toxic femininity that's
the face of it her face that whole
family it's a it's a hot mess so I don't
know I'm not going to blame the
Kardashians for what's happening to
Kanye in any way because I think he had
some troubled stuff going on with
himself before but I don't see how any
strong opinionated man survives that
place I don't I don't think it's
possible I mean I think that's why you
see the Pete Davidsons I mean these are
all just that's not I don't even know
that that's real but I don't think it
helped him to be in that culture you're
a strong opinionated guy who's going to
see the world differently potentially
than them you're not going to survive
that you're going to come out there
frustrated antagonized so I don't think
it helped to I think it caused some of
what we're seeing now in terms of his
kind no but I certainly don't think it
helped him to be to be on the more
stable side of issues um I just think he
needs to think like he needs to reflect
he needs to because you need to own what
you say you know and people need to
apologize if he doesn't feel that way he
should apologize if he does feel that
way he should own it and you know
consequences come when they come and if
companies don't want to associate with
him or whatnot he's going to have to
deal with that consequence but I find
him an incredibly odd figure when I list
him I find myself trying to decipher
what what and oftentimes I'm lost in a
cave I'm like what what is he saying
what's going on and I don't know if
that's uh people say oh it's mental hell
I don't know what it is is it just a guy
who's new to this component and trying
to figure out where he stands on stuff
out loud I don't know I really don't
quick response just on the Kardashian
thing
um just to kind of give you a a case
example
Connie has been very explicit he has
major problems with uh he I don't know
what he calls her exactly but uh Kris
Jenner like comment on Chris or general
Chris they kind of has like a little
funny word for her basically she's the
dictator right I believe it and the
problem that happened with my friend
what he's a good guy from is from the
Minneapolis Midwestern values when he
got into the family married they're like
all right this is the way we do things
around here this is the way we're going
to operate he's like yeah I don't I
don't want to do that and like to the
point where he's like yeah like you're
gonna move to Minneapolis and be a part
of like she's like are you [ __ ] kid
I'm staying in L.A like we're doing LA
and that was part they're like hey you
should probably have that conversation
before he got married but that was the
Whirlwind situation that that was but
here's a guy with like actual principles
and Midwestern good values that got you
know
infiltrated into this La Hollywood
toxic feminism scene that you're talking
about and it just obviously wouldn't
work but Kanye was been in that for 10
years like what kind of stuff do you
think that's happened to his mentality
since that so I think that I think even
if you're in it though like the
Kardashian Clan and what they do and
what they're capable of and all the
women and it's like there's something
odd even if you're in the entertainment
culture and in the entertainment
business I think there's something
deeply odd about the way they build
their their empire and the stuff that
they do and I I just I don't understand
why any Midwestern guy truthfully I
don't successful I don't I don't know
what the draw is there I mean I really
don't there's a whole lot of fake going
on anyone who markets themselves by the
way I always tell people as just pure
fake top to bottom there's a lot of
stuff going on behind the scenes
probably that you're not gonna like but
yeah I think that I think I believe that
I believe that you walk into that as a
guy and it's just like sit down shut up
we're gonna tell you how it's gonna go
that would certainly not work for a
Kanye which is why I would wonder why
you would even go there that's certainly
not going to work for any guy who wants
some autonomy over his own life and his
own media presence and his own I mean
it's like you walk in there and it's
like is it a contract do you sign a form
that you give your life away wouldn't
surprise me
um for the gift of being with a cartoon
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]